ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show here from london
across the pond with ben
avery our producer who flew in for what
48 hours yeah about that what a champ
what a champ that you would come all the
way
from your home
in california
i flew you what
business business class business class
all the way to london
and uh
you've just been on vacation for two
days you've had an amazing
you've had an amazing time you haven't
had to do much
you edited a patreon episode
you told everyone at dinner you cut your
own hair like we should be impressed
you just trotted that out like some type
of
you know accomplishment you cut your own
hair uh but it's lovely and now you know
we're on the uh we're on the eve of
returning to the dump that we live in
and i'm not really thrilled yeah
i'm really you know i i i could make a
go of it here
there's an ashtray on the thing i'm
covered how about you worry about you
worry about the sound levels
uh i can make a go of it here man i'm
kind of bummed to leave
i mean you know
as we're here the country of origin
our country of origin
is just
it's a deeply
schizophrenic
place
there's a real darkness there
that can only be truly appreciated when
you leave
now i'm sure this place would get boring
after a while because you know i don't
know it lacks
some of that
but for right now for the moment i mean
i just i'm kind of dreading
going back to america
the food here is good like you don't
feel like you're dying
when you eat
they don't have sugar in everything they
don't have like plastics
in the bread
like they're just hormones the gmos the
manipulated
[ __ ] that we
eat
they got fast food here they put it all
on like one street it's not every five
feet
things aren't open at 2am to get a full
meal
the lifts are smaller
which is elevator for you [ __ ]
american scumbags you don't know what
i'm talking about
the streets are smaller i mean you know
you just it's it's uh
being fat is not really tolerated
it's not tolerated and it it
you get it there's no big and tall
stores there's none of that you can't
get anything
i mean it's like we drove an hour to
some store i thought it'd be like a dxl
it was called bad rhino
think of that it was called bad
rhino
and it was not even a full store it was
just like a few shirts
in a fat women's store
in a shitty mall
an hour and a half out of london
they and i get it they're like let's not
celebrate that
you know i mean
i i i'm completely for that by the way
they're like let's not make it easy we
don't want it to be they had a dxl here
an american fat store they closed it
down
because you know like
it's not permitted and if you go further
into europe like paris or something i
mean or if you go to scandinavia god
help you
but i mean we're staying at the mandarin
oriental which is one of the greatest
hotels in the world if not the greatest
it's absolutely stunning and the uh
building next to us is the the famed one
hyde park where you know it's the most
expensive residential building in the
world the penthouse is on the market
right now for 200 i believe 296
million pounds and i might make an offer
i don't know i don't know if i will or
not
uh but you know it's a building full of
russian oligarchs and you know uh
i believe maybe
the candy brothers who developed it they
might be in business with the qataris i
think
and um
it's just lovely
it's just lovely and nobody's there and
nobody's ever home and there's very few
lights on
um because the best neighbors are not
home i mean that's something that
you know people don't realize but that's
why in all these really rich areas
you know you have a great situation
because the best neighbors are always
off somewhere doing a genocide like
they're not
they're not home they're not there to
complain
you know you don't have awkward run-ins
with them
outside you don't have to suffer through
small talk with people who are driving
past you in their lamborghini to go into
a bulletproof glass garage all of their
mail is getting sent through an x-ray
machine they're being guarded by the
equivalent of british special forces
none of those people oddly enough want
to tell you what they think about
everything
but i've lived in lots of
areas
where people cannot get enough of your
time
what's nice about russian oligarchs
uh sheiks
people from the united arab emirates
uh chinese amusement park tycoons people
uh russian gangsters in the uh
fertilizer business
indian mining magnets you know
uh brazilian uh uh mining magnus maybe
it's brazil that has the mines i i don't
know but like you know what's really
nice about them is they really keep
their opinions to themself
they are a lesson they don't even want
you to know that they are your neighbor
what a lovely idea
now there's a premium to live in a
building like that there's one flat on
sale flat means apartment for you
american uh non-healthcare having scum
suckers that i have to see tomorrow
but uh flat is a in an apartment and
there's one flat on sale for five
million don't think i didn't call my
business manager we can't do it it's too
out of range but um and then the next
one up is 17 million but that is the
premium that you pay that is the premium
that you pay to live in a building where
people don't want you to know they also
live there could there be a better
arrangement
seriously could there be a better
arrangement
in life than living in a essentially a
hotel
for uh billionaire criminals
they keep to
themselves
they don't bother you
they don't they don't oh what oh the
what do you think about the game huh
what do you think about these uh trans
kids in the schools
they don't get into that
right from the lambo to the apartment
that's it
they're not just going off on whatever
the issue of the day is
they don't get on a soapbox they're not
trying to be heard they're not getting
you in the hallway did you see tucker
you know
what they're doing now
is they're making kids transition
in gym class
see you can get away from all that i
mean that is the answer it is the only
answer and you know people are going to
get mad at me again they're going to go
well
how am i supposed to live in one hard
part well that's not my problem i can't
manage your life i can't even live there
i'm just saying as
as things go
as goals go
it's a much better situation for someone
like me who's just a little tired of
people's opinions i'm a little tired of
the unsolicited opinions of friends
neighbors family co-workers uh you know
i i am now seeing the value uh in the
type of privacy that can only be
attained uh by living uh with dictators
who have a healthy degree of paranoia
because many people want revenge on them
for the things they've done
it's a nice place to live it's a lovely
and then you know i like the guy from
the spectator who came to the thing he's
very sweet but you know he's [ __ ] on
one hyde park and that guy lives in what
putney or
scumsberry hey shut up like what are you
talking about oh you can't live there oh
knightsbridge why would you want to live
there hey shut up and i like him but
let's get real
if i come to london and i may this is
the only spot for me i can't live
anywhere else
harrods is such a great [ __ ] store i
don't fit in anything i went to
christian dior and i said i'll spend any
amount of money do you have a three axe
and she said she did let me tell you
right now the 3x would not have fit you
i went into the dressing room with the
3x
it was like i mean
putting that on it was like i was on
ayahuasca shapes were changing i
couldn't get my bearings i'd stepped
into another realm
i felt like i was on i didn't know my
hands looked bigger and smaller i was
trying to fit into this 3x and it was
mortifying and it was terrible i could
because you know the uk it's different
than america
it's very different the sizes here and
finally i came out and of course i
didn't come out wearing it because i
would have looked absurd
i came out and i was like oh you only
have a navy blue i wanted it in brown
and she's like we don't have it in brown
i'm like thank god
and i just ran out of there
but our agent likes harrods which is
interesting because he's plus size and i
wouldn't think he'd like harrods but
then you go they have three food courts
in harrods so i go oh
they're also selling rib eyes and sticky
toffee pudding
so i get why he likes it
but you know
i mean this is just a place for me i've
i've had enough ben's watched the
masters for the last 10 hours
uh you know it's it's uh
it's a lovely place to be
you know and then uh you know
then you just keep checking twitter in
america and everybody's fighting about
uh disney
you know
people just screaming
there's people outside of disney with
the ten commandments
you know again i just i i think i want
to get citizenship somewhere else no i'm
dead serious i want to get citizenship
somewhere else i don't think it works
out and i kind of don't want to be a
part of it anymore whatever it is on
both sides
on the side where it's like they think
every teacher is a groomer trying to
[ __ ] their fat children
and on the other side of like we should
let three-year-olds uh you know cut
their dicks off in the middle of math
i'm both uh on both sides i can no
longer participate in my country i
really don't even want to it's become an
embarrassment to live there
um it's become an embarrassment to live
in a country
where uh many of our major streets are
lined with tents that people live in but
all of the uh all of the headlines are
about when hotels are gonna open in
space
everyone's getting into watches right
now i love them you know why because
they're great they tell the time they i
mean watches are and they're also it it
tells somebody about you and what you
value it's a beautiful thing to do
vincero is a premium lifestyle brand in
san diego carrying incredible eyewear
watches and much more if you don't know
them yet there's no better time to check
them out than now they just released the
argo automatic a collector quality dive
watch you need to check out which is
awesome for all the socal people
wherever you are that like to dive and
surf and everything
it's great they create exceptionally
crafted ethically made products for
today's most ambitious people modern
pieces that elevate your look and stand
the test of time they're adamant about
the process they design everything
in-house they source their own materials
produce in small batches and ship right
to you and they're really they're
affordable i mean this is you know the
argo named after the mythological greek
ship crafted by the gods perfect blend
form function style utility
high
powered citizen myota 901 automatic
movement fluted uni-directional rotating
bezel swiss loom hands divers claps come
on man i love argo it's an amazing watch
i mean you gotta do it it's great check
them out at v i n c e r o collective dot
com forward slash tim dillon that's
dot
v-i-n-c-e-r-o-collective.com
forward slash tim dillon they support
the podcast that you know and love and
it's great to buy a watch i'm telling
you go to ventura collective forward
slash tim dillon and check out this new
watch the argo automatic it's collector
quality
it's beautiful how do you do you and
this watch i have it ventro
and what about it it's the most
beautiful watch i've ever owned it's of
course
and and i i want and so what is this
promotion here
vincero was offering a special 20
and free shipping to our listeners with
code tim dillon support our show and
check them out
vincerocollective.com forward slash tim
dillon 20 off and free shipping
have they lost their minds
well they haven't because they know that
it's such a great product
become embarrassing and i know elon just
bought us uh he's the largest
shareholder in twitter tell us about
that about 11. this is big news
because elon musk what happened to the
tunnel he was building between what
happened to the tunnels has he given up
on the tunnels
remember when i was on rogan and we were
talking about these magical tunnels that
elon musk why don't you build a tunnel
under austin to help the traffic except
the tunnel doesn't you go underground
and you never come above ground the
tunnel just leads and it just drops you
into some like hole in the ground that
you can never come out of how about that
that'd be a great tunnel but i guess
we've given up on the tunnel the
ambitious tunnel system that was going
to get rid of traffic um and there's the
mars expedition but now he's buying
twitter which i'm for
i like the idea that he wants free
speech back on twitter but i think the
better idea is to just shut twitter the
[ __ ] down
that's everybody's real take that really
thinks about it the best thing to do
would be to stop trying to make
meaningful arguments in 140 characters
or less
get the [ __ ] off it and move to one hyde
park in knightsbridge and if you can't
do that kill yourself
because there's nothing else to do maybe
pollock's peak in hong kong
perhaps but the language barrier is
something it's not nothing over there
but that is also i guess and there's
smog
but i mean so what's he doing tell
everyone what elon musk is doing on
twitter elon musk bought ten percent how
much of twitter did he buy you bought
nine percent of twitter percent of
twitter how many shares is that benjamin
let's see because he made quite a quite
some cash on here yes and some of the
people at twitter are mad they're like
elon made me money but i still don't
like him
3 billion and then it surged by 26 in
response to the news the stock well
lovely and now what's he doing he's
trying to get an edit button
and he's trying you know he's got some
concerns
about the draconian
uh policies we're seeing on a lot of
these tech sites good for him yeah he
wants to open source the algorithm
uh what does that mean speak english uh
the choice of which algorithm to use or
not should be open to everyone
interesting so you could go on what like
a hate timeline you go i want to go on a
hate timeline today you could curate
whatever you wanted you could curate
whatever you want so it's just not only
twitter feeding it you can feed yourself
you can go i want to go on a timeline of
just celebrities and shootings
i want kardashians and school shootings
today that's my mood
i want to oscillate between meaningless
celebrity gossip and the bodies of dead
children
you can pick and choose you can curate
your timeline i want a little queuing on
today
i want a little q a on today and i like
some motivational uh
speaking
i want some bitcoin and q
i want a little q and a little coin
on the timeline today that's what my
timeline is it's just bitcoin
trans people
ever and and uh q and on related
activities that is my entire twitter
timeline it's bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin
trans trans trans
and still some
you know
rehabilitated version of q and on that
still lives on to this day
uh that involves the ukraine and hillary
and hunter biden
and trump and everything and and i don't
know what's on hunter biden's laptop the
guy just fled to switzerland the media
clearly wanted biden to win they
sandbagged the hunter biden laptop story
they said it was russian disinformation
they lied uh they wanted uh biden to win
they had uh they had a dog in the fight
and they you know so if you're still
like this whole idea that the media is
even objective or ever was objective
is not true it's a fallacy so if you
believe that i guess you're perpetually
shocked by all of these things but there
is another media
uh where they they did report on the
story or as much of the story as they
could report on and that way you know
obviously the mainstream carries a lot
of weight and they were the ones that
kind of you know diminished the story
but it was still out there but what is
on the laptop he's smoking crying who
takes all these photos of themselves
and crack
like has anyone asked that question why
why are you photographing like i
understand if you're [ __ ] a hooker
and you think it's hot
it's still not a good idea to just take
80 000 images how many images are there
there's lots how many
but why is the why does he have like 20
000 images of him smoking crap i've
never even thought about it is he being
blackmailed
but but they're on his laptop it's so
weird yeah he's just cracked out in
motels and most of them there's it's
weird stuff but no one thought biden was
going to win so he's a weird guy to
blackmail hunter but while his dad was
the vp
biden was the vp
but so i'm i'm wondering like
maybe this is a blackmail thing but why
would you have thousands of photos
there's photos of him just sleeping in
bed with a crack pipe hanging out of his
mouth
and and you go can someone explain to me
who took that photo i guess a hooker
yeah and there's orgy photos too orgy
picks him with hook where are the orgy
pics i mean i saw one of them he was
like
he was he had a hooker's he was like
choking her out with a stocking or
something
i saw one with squirtle on the bed a pet
uh stuffed squirtle and him and a hooker
what's a is that a pokemon it's a
pokemon he's like pretending to bang her
from the back and there's just a
squirtle in the he's an artist
[Music]
i mean the guy's an artist
so i mean is it really appropriate to go
through all of his sexual peccadillos
he's an artist
the man's an artist who was involved in
it with a gas company in the ukraine
for his art
what was he doing in the ukraine oh
there was a uh he had a deal with a gas
company there but he also had some sort
of i'm gonna uh look this up real quick
but supposedly that might have been a
distraction from their dealings with
china too because they were investing in
some companies over there what
qualifications does he have
to do any of this no i'm curious did he
go to school uh did he graduate from
school
did hunter biden get a degree in
anything
and is it
in any type of field that would make you
imagine
that he has some kind of expertise and
energy okay so he went to georgetown
university that's a good one and then
after that he went to yale law school
okay so he's he he at one point
he was somewhat qualified but okay
and what did he get at this a lawyer
let's see here
um
and of course daddy helps get you into
all these places i'm not blind but if
you get through them if you get through
georgetown and you get through yale
you at least have some level of you know
i can understand how he got involved
uh in you know in in whatever scam he
was doing he's an attorney so he's a
bachelor of arts degree in history from
georgetown university and then he became
a lawyer after that so it's just
mfa in law how does he get involved with
the ukraine
uh how does he get involved because
we're trying to figure out the real
story here because my twitter timeline
says that he's run you know the whole
game
hillary and him
and all of these people are undeterred
they're not dissuaded by the fact that
everything they've believed hasn't come
true
nobody's in gitmo
nobody's there's been no
you know like uh any type of
reckoning in the way they imagined and
yet the the
troubling amount of schizophrenics in
the country
are are are so i'm trying to weave
through
that narrative and find what's true we
know he smokes crack that seems
that's beyond uh any type of debate i
don't think that's not a conspiracy
theory he enjoys crack cocaine he likes
hookers and that goes along with crack
if you're going to smoke crack you don't
go read the kids in libraries you [ __ ]
hookers my curiosity is why he's
involved with the ukraine
okay so here uh it actually i have to by
the way we got to edit a few jokes out
of my special because the ukraine is
just
unfortunately you know you do a few
light bits
and then uh you know the there's bodies
everywhere and i mean it's just like hey
you know it's you know it just we gotta
get a few of the bits gotta get edited
out of the special they would throw away
bit you know a couple of one-liners in
the front but
and we don't know if we're gonna drop
the specialist an hour or if we're gonna
just drop in eclipse we don't know yet
nobody watches an hour we're debating
that but we got to get to ukraine out
because maybe putin uses a chemical
weapon or a dirty bomb in there or
maybe i don't know what happens but it
just you know it's getting to the point
now where it's not not that it was ever
funny but you know it's just getting to
the point where it's really not funny
it's you know it's to a point now where
you know i feel like it's in poor taste
to do a few of the uh you know lower the
gas price bits that we were than i was
doing
things you've heard on the podcast
already and they were going over well
but sure you know it's unfortunate now
they had a thing in bukhar
i don't know how to say it but uh
you know the russian troops went in
there
and um
[Music]
our
i mean the term is massacre
the term is janet you know i'm not there
but it's certainly you know from the
pictures and from people that
are you know you know reporting from the
ukraine it certainly doesn't look good
300 plus found dead yeah 300 plus yeah
well it's not you know i mean it's bad
but
just in pure numbers
to be honest in pure numbers
i mean we've done 300 easy
so it is you know but i'm not i'm not
one of these people who excuses
everything the russians do like there's
people on twitter now that we're
everything the russians do they're like
well let's take a look at this
and i'm like no no i think i i think a
sovereign country was invaded
uh
russia's in the wrong it's you know
i i mean i still don't want a nuclear
war
i still don't think that we should be uh
enforcing a no-fly zone in the conflict
is i don't think it should grow in scope
but
mud water is a coffee alternative with
four aptigenetic mushrooms with
ayurvedic herbs with one-seventh of the
caffeine is a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety jitters or
crash of coffee
each ingredient was added benjamin with
a purpose cacao and chai from mood and a
micro dose of caffeine lion's mane for
alertness cordyceps to help physical
performance chaga and rishi to support
your immune system turmeric for soreness
and cinnamon for antioxidants isn't your
wife allergic to cinnamon yes well none
of this for her
but mud is whole30 approved 100 usda
organic non-gmo gluten free vegan and
kosher certified
mud water has launched their new evening
ritual the rest plant a non-caffeinated
tea that promotes relaxation and rest
because the best morning ritual starts
the night before go to mudwater.com
tim to support the show and use code tim
for five percent off we all need energy
right now whatever you're doing arguing
with people on twitter living your best
life exercising going on dates getting
back into the groove post pandemic you
know that you need energy i need energy
everybody needs energy and you know
where i get my energy from mud water mud
water does it because there's no crash
sure you could eat a mcflurry or
mcgriddle or something but mud water is
healthy they've got all this stuff
they've chosen for you to be healthy you
don't need energy and then a crash
so go right now walk don't run don't
walk to mud water m-u-d-w-t-r
that's m-u-d-w-t-r
t-i-m-support the show use code
t-i-m-mud
water five dollars off for mudwater how
many times do i have to tell you people
about the raycon wireless earbuds
they're the best way to bring audio with
you because no matter where you shake
things up to literally you know matter
how much you shake it won't fall out of
your ears they've got several different
settings they've got an alertness mode
in case you want to stay alert when
you're out jogging maybe in a major city
they offer eight hours of play time 32
hours battery life and they're priced
just right you get quality audio for
half the price of other premium audio
brands it's no wonder raycon's everyday
earbuds have over 48 000 five-star
reviews they're less than half the price
of other premium earbuds and they work
better they have longer play time
they're more stylish i'm telling you
right now i have ray connie your buds do
you have them i have them you should
because they're phenomenal i love them
and you'll love them i'm telling you
it's better don't go with the go with
the your gut here i'm telling you i
would i lie
raycon earbuds they're everywhere
i see people with them in their ears and
i know they're a good person and they're
sharp and they're smart right now tim
dillington listeners can get 15 off to
raycon order it by recon dot com slash
tim that's by
raycon.com save 15
on raycons it's a great way to show
people that you love the tim dillon show
and that you're you're serious about
what you put in your ears
raycon is the brand you're saving money
you're saving money without a promo code
and we're giving you a promo code it's
by
raycon.com tim
and you save 15 percent
have you been able to find out
what hunter biden is up to in the
ukraine oh yeah yeah i was looking at
the china stuff too which was
interesting uh because what's he doing
in china okay so uh what kind of crack
they have over in china so from an email
from hunter biden in august 2017 it
indicated he was receiving a 10 million
annual fee from a chinese billionaire
for introductions alone though it is
unclear who was involved in alleged
introductions and it says
in 2013 hunter flew aboard air force two
with his father who was then vice
president on an official visit to
beijing where the younger biden met
investment banker jonathan lee hunter
told the new yorker he just met him for
a cup of coffee but 12 days after the
trip a private equity fund bhr partners
was approved by the chinese authorities
mr lee was chief executive hunter was a
board member he would hold a 10
stake
yeah okay i'm i'm um he resigned from
the board of bhr in april 2020 but still
held his 10 stake in bhr as of july this
year
uh so then the new york post reported in
april 2015 in which an advisor to
barisma which is a right that's the big
one i don't know if i'm saying it right
barisma barisma it's a gas company in
ukraine right natural gas and then the
emo apparently thanked hunter biden for
inviting him to meet his father in
washington hunter was a director on the
board of uh this a ukrainian-owned
private energy
hunter was killing it
like he was doing well this is what they
do with these people the politicians you
know
at what point did he throw this all away
to just smoke crack
do you know what i mean like i'm trying
to analyze it from that perspective like
here's a guy
daddy's the vp
he's making all the introductions he's
getting paid
real money
at what point does the crack addiction
be just become untenable where he can no
longer perform said duties
you know and i'm sure all of this is
shady and underhanded and whatever and
you know but at what point
why is hunter not out in front where is
hunter
that like these are questions i have
like where is he
what happened why is he not more like
what is the deal did they just put him
somewhere for the election like
i mean is the guy not like like roger
clinton or tiffany trump the fat
daughter did they just like put them
somewhere
where is hunter biden right now is he in
one hyde park is he next to us i think
he's in malibu
is he in the booth this
secret service renting mansion for over
30 000 to protect hunter biden they
chose the malibu property to be as close
as possible to the president's son
report says
huh
dream dinner me
you
hunter biden caitlyn jenner
i mean in malibu sunset
nobu
just beautiful
[Music]
with two great with two patriots
four if you count us
so hunter biden's in malibu but i'm
trying to like
he's a wild guy his his brother died and
he started banging his brother's wife
yeah some of that's on her though
right
hunter's just kind of being hunter in
that scenario like some of that has got
to be on her what kind of woman
starts banging the crackhead
so now
they refuse
get gensaki up who refuses to answer any
questions about hunter biden now now
this idiot here's what i'm here's where
i'm having trouble with all this you got
this guy
he brings his laptop in
for a repair and and delaware why
what kind of crack is he on and i've
said this before on the show
where he's like doesn't he have access
to bit like why is he bringing his lap
doesn't he have a guy
you would think right why is he bringing
what is he going to the geek squad what
is he doing
he's getting 10 mil a year to set up
investment bankers in china
why is he
i i i i'm confused but i guess he's
smoking crap
so all of the holes in the hunter biden
story go back to the fact that he's
smoking krill which is a nickname for
crack from the old days when i was uh
out there
uh misbehaving
never like hunter but
it wasn't great
i got jensaki here
you want to hear her yeah
because they refuse to even they pretend
like this guy's not alive
they act like hunter biden doesn't exist
a lot of stories about hunter biden
servicing this week so to ensure the
independence of the investigation would
the president support the appointment of
a special counsel
well first the president has never had a
conversation with the department of
justice about any investigations into
any member of his family he said that
during the campaign and he will continue
to abide by that so i appointed the
department of justice for any additional
steps they would take they would make
those decisions independently is there
any concern that they're not going to be
necessarily seen as being able to make
the decisions independently the white
house chief of staff is out saying
that
the president is confident his son did
not break the law
well that's something the president has
said and certainly we would echo but in
the same answer to that question peter
during an interview this week on abc ron
clayne also said the justice department
is independent and they will make their
own decisions and the president has said
that he never
spoke to his son about his overseas
business dealings is that still the case
yes
that's a lie
but i don't know what hunter did it was
illegal
that can be proved i know hunter's done
a lot of things that are illegal white
collar blue collar all kinds of you know
but i don't know what he
what can be proved is it a campaign
finance violation is it
because this is what they do all the
time they make a lot of money they they
make introductions they
i'm unaware of what he i mean obviously
the crack
and the hookers right
but then the q and r people are going
there's human cha there's proof of human
trafficking
on his laptop which maybe is true or i
don't know
i i don't know but i don't know what the
justice department is looking into i
haven't seen that confirmed that there's
we're not going to see it confirmed
i don't even think they mean cp i mean
i'm sure the q and on people do but i
think they mean like
traffic hookers we also have to stop the
idea that every hooker is human traffic
can we cut it out
everyone with a [ __ ] job is human
traffic everybody was thrown in a van
and taken to denny's without a choice
this is how some people make a living
so yes some of them may be traffic but
some of them are just showing up to make
a
so
i just where i just don't know so this
guy's in like hiding in malibu
and and he's not can he make a statement
i guess probably lawyers are advising
him not to this is from february imagine
they're advising him not to uh yeah so
this is from february 27th bye
again go into this now for people that
are like me they're behind the eight
ball because i don't even live in
america anymore so i don't really give a
[ __ ] i just want to hang out with boris
johnson uh
so now
all right so take us back to this entire
thing with the like this guy that
discovered the laptop just fled to
i believe sweden
it's on drudge he he fears retaliation
from the white house
supposedly he's downloading thousands of
images off
the hunter biden laptop and i was this
the guy that he brought it to originally
you know
this guy has fled the country which i
get because he he doesn't want you know
he doesn't want the old michael hastings
treatment
here for the daily mail whistleblower
who handed hunter's abandoned laptop to
congressman
dailymail.com reveals he has 450
gigabytes of deleted material including
80 000 images and videos and is fled to
switzerland okay
fearing retaliation from the white house
who has 80 000 images that's crazy on
their on their laptop
right
there's something here folks
and 120 000 emails that's that's insane
there's something here folks i i don't
know what it is but i'm i'm coming at
this in a non-ideological way i'm just
look if any of this is true
120 000 archived emails well
the emails are not is as much of a thing
for me
80 000 images
that does make you think there's
something wrong
you know what i mean right that he's
paying for large transfers of images to
have on his laptop like he clearly
didn't take him so then who knows what
it was
but uh hey let me let me take you don't
you understand when you got rid of
jeffrey and just lane this is what
happens you have crackheads running the
show now
let's be very honest about it look at
where jeffrey and gislane lived chizlane
came from england
look
it's not right we know it's not right
okay
but if you're gonna run a global human
trafficking ring
do you want
jizzling maxwell who spent her life
mixing with royals knows which fork to
use with a salad
wears probably vintage cavalli i'm
guessing doesn't look great i mean the
hair she kind of looked like a a wet dog
sometimes did the best she could with
what she had she's not a great beauty
it's the uk it's not brazil the women
are what they are but the point is do
you want her and epstein a little egg
penis brooklyn math teacher
do you want them or do you want this guy
smoking rock in malibu
whose father's got dementia
[ __ ] his dead brother's wife
do you see what i mean
it's a terribly unpopular point i'm
making and it's hard to make
but it involves the realities of the oh
i saw light go on in one hyde park go on
go go back into this where is this man
from switzerland and let's get him on
the program
uh okay so let's see here so his name is
jack
maxey can we if we release the special
eclipse can we release 5 000 hunter
biden images with every comedy clip i
release
can we make a deal with him get our fat
agent on the phone say that we're gonna
do a drop every monday it's gonna be a
comedy drop with 15 000 images from
hunter biden's laptop
can't we
yeah it's like an nft right it's
yeah maybe
bitcoin conferences this weekend we
didn't go we're in london we don't live
in america
we're not going to some big convention
center
okay so he gave daily mail they wouldn't
pass what we wanted but go on he gave a
copy of the hard drive from hunter's
abandoned laptop in the spring of 2021.
he also gave copies and material from it
to the washington post new york times
and senator chuck grassley well that
fell on deaf ears they had no interest
the new york times was like delete
he claims they all sat on it for months
for the past two weeks and this is from
february 27th maxie has been hiding in
zurich working with it experts to dig
out more data from the laptop from hell
he's a former co-host of a laptop from
hell
what a great book
and now
abc's movie of the week
the laptop from hell
this guy looks like a class act well
he's uh a co-host of x donald trump
advisor steve bannon's podcast the war
room
is this who whitney webb is trying to
set me up with oh is it i don't know if
it is then we got we'll get him on the
show this is his name maxie his name's
max i don't know it listen
well here's the problem they there's no
problem killing us
maybe that's why this guy goes he goes
if i'm gonna go on a show i'll go on
this thing they'll kill them
steve bannon probably told him kill
these [ __ ]
steve bannon's like don't get me killed
get a younger version of me killed and i
don't agree with steve bannon on a lot
of what he says and i and and my skin
looks great sometimes
but the point is
that is if this is who she's trying to
set us up with we'll have this guy on
we'll go to switzerland tomorrow can you
message her and ask her
is it this guy because we will interview
tell her go is it this guy we will go to
switzerland tomorrow and interview this
guy i will go to switzerland uh tomorrow
and we will interview this guy later in
the week if this is
what i think it is but if if it's not i
mean we're not i don't want some hack on
here but if it's this guy
i'm not trying to get killed either but
i mean at least let's get killed over
something 80 000 images jesus christ
i've got like 40 images on my phone and
15 of them are of scones
was this guy a former white house
staffer for trump
is he i don't know ben you're the one
who does the research i'm the comic uh
genius and the cultural commentator
you're the back office
i'm wondering if it's not this guy i
don't think it is this guy we also tried
to get jk rowling we wanted to go to
edinburgh
and have jk rowling uh you know come out
with the the
you know the you know the the the
figures of the man and the woman with
the you know the the stick
what what's that the pointer and she
point you know should we wanted to do a
thing with her which she'd point to the
genitals the whole thing
i wanted to interview her as hagrid
and where she would make great points
but i would interview her as her
creation hagrid the groundskeeper from
harry potter and and and she would make
points about bio biological
uh essentialism
uh in terms of gender and i would sit
there as hagrid and probably agree with
a lot of it but we tried to get jk
rowling and i mean that [ __ ] i can't
even message her i can't even get tulsi
gabbard on again the nell kids who i
love but they have they have trump they
have [ __ ]
they got ch what's your name caitlyn
jenner on i can't get tulsi gabbard on
and i i i [ __ ] offered to do the
interview in moscow
it should hit hard folks it should hit
real hard
right now
the demands on people's emotional health
are more than i've ever seen
we live in a time of stress of chaos
uh a time of disorienting change
uh people are are mortgaging their
emotional well-being they are not taking
the time to uh care about their
emotional
fitness
uh so what do you do you need better
help
better help is
online therapy
that offers
some really really amazing results they
have online counselors you can start
communicating in under 48 hours if you
don't like your counselor you can always
switch they have counseling that may not
be available
in your physical location it's
inexpensive i i've used it all of my
friends use it
i'm telling you right now it's a great
way to get yourself from the comfort of
your own home you can put yourself
on the path to wellness which is
something that we don't talk enough
about
is is mental health
and and wellness
and i am a proponent of
people not being uh crazy
isn't it nice when when you bump into
someone and your first thought is not
what a loon
and so there's a way to do that and the
way to do that is to go to
betterhealth.com
b-e-t-t-e-rhelp.com tim d you get 10 off
the first month of betterhelp.com it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy i'm telling you give it a try
and see if online therapy can lower your
stress level it's customized for you
they offer video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to this is customized for
your comfort level i'm telling you right
now you won't regret it you'll be
mentally healthier physically healthier
you'll feel better you'll be more
focused at work you'll be more present
during the day present in your
relationships you'll be a better friend
it can all happen betterhelp.com
tim d b-e-t-t-e-r-a-t-l-p
dot com slash tim d you're moments away
from uh this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp you are moments away
from feeling better about the world
what a us news pc magazine and popular
science have in common they all rank
simply save home security as the best
home security of 2021 in fact us news
just named simply saved the best home
security of 2022. you have simply safe i
live in a high rise where i don't need
it but most people i know that live in
homes right now are taking extra care to
keep themselves and their family safe
simply safe protects your whole home
around the clock every door window and
room it's backed by the best 24 7
professional monitoring in the business
ready to dispatch police firefighters or
emts to your home with a comprehensive
set of sensors and cameras including uh
the all-new wireless outdoor security
camera you always know what's going on
inside and outside your home simply safe
is less than one dollar a day and you
can get it set up in around 30 minutes
and it's always simple to use there's
never a long term contract you can even
try it for 60 days free to see if you
like it if you don't send it back free
of charge simply save protect over a
million homes in the united states alone
you can customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simplisafe.com s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash tim dillon
go right now and claim a free indoor
security camera plus 20 off with
interactive monitoring did you hear that
it's a free indoor security camera plus
20 off with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com
tim dillon now
what's this man's name this guy from
switzerland oh he's not from switzerland
but he's hiding in switzerland so he's
got 80 000 images from this laptop so he
has spent the last few months just jerk
it off
i mean i guess he says there's images of
drug trafficking prostitution and
criminal activity
well we know that and he's going to make
it all public is what he says
is that a crime after the fat like it
might be can he be
charged if a photo comes out with you
smoking crack with a prostitute ben and
i pray every day it does
if a photo comes out is that a can they
charge you with a crime
uh i think so but jack said that the fbi
never filed hunter biden's laptop into
evidence so jack the jack maxey oh the
guy so he said the fbi just you know
ignored it like you know you see time
and time again where something's they go
to the fbi they give them a bunch of
evidence and they i don't know i have a
i have a good amount of faith in the fbi
and they really seem to follow up on
everything
i mean from my experience
they do i mean
i mean what is the fbi
not followed up on i mean they're just
they just get it done so here's here's
uh here's the order here's the handoff
the only thing the fbi doesn't follow up
on is the thing is the crimes that the
fbi themselves
uh have initiated and uh curated which
is the vast majority of things they're
investigating okay so
in 2019 the laptop was abandoned at the
delaware computer store the owner is his
name is john mack isaac he gave a copy
to trump's lawyer rudy giuliani who then
passed it on to maxie so then
he says i came here so that we could do
a forensic examination of hunter's
laptop safely in a country that still
respects human liberty and the ideals of
liberal democratic principles and great
chocolate
he said i do not believe this would have
been possible inside the united states
we had numerous attempts on us from
trying to do things like this there
uh
maxie said that after contacting daily
mail about the laptop last year black
suburban suvs appeared outside his house
and former us intelligence officers
trying to protect him oh maybe yeah
that's probably what was happening
they're probably trying to protect him
he said he kept receiving strange calls
uh
uh and former u.s intelligence officers
friends he shared copies with told them
that they received strange calls
i showed this to a friend of mine in
desperation in february 2021 because
nobody would listen to me no news
organizations would take it in fact the
very first major news organization to
take it was daily mail very dear friends
of mine the sharp tip of the spear were
making welfare calls to me every day
basically to see if i was still alive
maxie claimed one former intelligence
agency senior staffer told him soon
after he received the hard drive in 2020
if you don't release enough of this so
that they know you can release all of it
i'm telling you brother you're a dead
man maxie took their advice on october
2020 and posted batches of emails and
other files from the laptop on file
sharing sites but after an hour the
links were taken down maxie says he
believes the us government was hunting
down files from the laptop posted online
and flagged them to the companies there
were five drop boxes two in the us one
in new zealand two and you know it's the
most disturbing thing about this whole
story because biden has like dimension
alzheimer's
like he he has to you have to keep
explaining to him what's happening
all right so sit down let's go over this
again
your son is on crack
bo no bo's dead
hunter yes hunter's on crack he's
[ __ ] hookers and he's got a lot of
shady deals in the ukraine
and they've got to probably do that
three or four times a week with him
so this is a full-scale kind of all-out
war to prevent what's ever on this
laptop getting out
because best case is really embarrassing
but i think worst case it proves there's
some criminal activity so now i'm
getting it's coming together more
where and the the bigger thing is uh
what trump tried to make issue out of
hunter biden's dealings with ukraine
russia and china which included high
paid consultancies and gifts and
allegations that as vp joe biden had
shaped american foreign policy in
ukraine to benefit his son
well that's a little bit of a stretch
because the foreign policy in ukraine
has always been designed to benefit the
united states of america
which is a country
uh
that is
based on fraud and deception and lies
and so
i mean i'm sure what's good for the
goose is good for the gander you know
it's like
yeah i mean hunter's not the only
businessman running over there smoking
crack with hookers
you know you know putting his [ __ ]
beak in the trough
you know not that by the way it's
completely inappropriate when your
father's the vice president but it's not
like american policy isn't that anyway
like i'm sure america's goal is not out
there to spread democracy america's goal
is to be out there to get you know
willing trading partners and trade
routes and control of ports and
uh you know all kinds of things and
you know they want uh economic you have
economic interest in all these countries
so yeah i have no doubt that doesn't
mean it's it's it's good that you know
putin's over there in buca making soup
out of people
but
for sure let's be let's be honest about
what america's interest in the ukraine
is we didn't give a [ __ ] about the
ukraine
america's interest in the ukraine is a
is a financial and uh
geopolitical strategy like every country
just like russia's interest just like
china's interest but what's interesting
about this laptop is all of this came
out because a crackhead abandoned a
laptop
in a dell why would you even have a
laptop fixed
it's just such a
i mean people got to look at hunter and
be like what the [ __ ]
i mean jill seems pretty with it it's
her son right you wonder if she calls
him and goes you know you're a real
disgrace
i mean he this is black sheep of the
family
the literal term black sheep
is to abandon a laptop with 80 000
images of you smoking crack and punching
hookers
and then 120 000 emails of shady
business dealings in china and ukraine
while your father is running for
president
like oh his mom died in a car accident
by the way it wasn't jill just
correcting oh okay
well this is maybe why he's using the
crack right i mean there's problems
there the biden family has problems
maybe he was disturbed by the fact that
his father kept referring to the inner
cities as jungles
[Laughter]
maybe that made him start uh
maybe that made him start experimenting
with out of mind experiences
so jen saki who by the way has the
energy of a woman scorned right like
every time you see her she's just the
energy of a woman who was told like an
hour earlier like she is the energy of a
woman who finds a text from her
husband's lover on her phone and it's a
man or something you know like
she is just uh i mean god and supposedly
she's leaving right she going to msnbc
is he going to pay her a lot of money
that that's what i heard that shensaki
is leaving
but they're just they're pretending this
doesn't exist but this is gonna kind of
be
yes msnbc unless the only way this
doesn't get bigger is if this implicates
some republicans too
i don't know
you know i mean
i it would shock me if it did because i
mean they're an honest upstanding crew
but i mean perhaps there's some
bipartisan shenanigans you know is he
the only picture on there with the
hookers and the blow
it's so weird to me to take that many
photos when you have that many photos on
your own [ __ ] laptop god are you an
idiot
god you an idiot
it seems to me
could it be possible
he's being blackmailed
there's some level of blackmail they're
they're emailing him these photos i
don't know i don't know i don't think so
no i mean he was uh supposedly so not
only does he have a child with uh london
roberts
with uh now who's london rapper
he has a three-year-old unacknowledged
child supposedly
uh then uh on top of all of this he's
not a good father
[Music]
i mean now i'm starting to question his
character she's a stripper
i am
really really
losing my faith in america
right now hunter biden
has a child that he refuses to
acknowledge
with someone named london robert
and with the first name of london she is
shockingly a stripper
is this
child
trans
because i want to spend four hours
talking about that
and only that
where is london roberts at can we get
her on the show
probably
uh he also stayed with a woman named zoe
kesten
who's like a uh
um
lingerie and textile designer spent five
hours giving testimony on biden spending
where he would stay at the chateau
vermont in los angeles where in 2018 he
was preoccupied with cooking crack
cocaine
hard not to like him you know i mean to
be honest with you like he stays at
really cool places
you know it's hard for me to judge a
substance abuser as long as all the
women were of age that he was choking
you know and as long as it was
consensual
bdsm
it's hard to get mad at a guy who's just
trying to get his beak wet in the
ukraine and smoke a little krill with a
few ladies
but again it's uh not right if his
father is making policy
that's at all influenced by his son but
i don't i mean that seems like a weird
thing
but not impossible
but again i think the policy is just
like yeah we want to pillage the ukraine
like we just want to
so hunter's just like let's send hunters
like the marines did you send him in
first
let's send hunter in let's see what
happens
he'll he'll find out where all the good
brothels are
he'll figure out where you can score
you know
and then we'll get the rest of the
[ __ ] ugly americans great ben mes and
rick book we'll get the rest of them
over there
to do the same thing but where are we at
now i mean he's not been charged with
anything we have this guy in switzerland
going i'm gonna release photos of the
laptop
and uh they're looking into uh whether
hunter biden correctly met tax
obligations during a period in which by
his own telling he was being paid 50 000
a month by ukrainian firm burisma
or biden's financial ties to foreign
figures and businesses while his father
served as barack obama's number two so
they're also looking into the tax thing
uh but obviously people say a legal
lobbying was also an issue that shadowed
trump throughout his presidency people
right now that are worrying about what
your kids learn in school which is
something you should worry about but
don't you see what your kids end up
doing to you in the long run
don't you get it
you're worried about what your kids are
learning in school but let me tell you
right now it's only a matter of time
before they're smoking crack in hong
kong [ __ ] you all up
or shanghai
whatever keeve
don't you understand that
it comes back to bite you stop with the
helicopter parenting
they need to learn responsibility and if
they cut their dick off and they don't
want it and they want their dick back
well that's a big oops
i'm against that by the way i'm against
them cutting their dicks off
i'm i am
i'm thrown by this whole hunter biden
thing i think there's something there 80
000 images is very weird
it's very strange regardless the federal
tax probe is moving forward a federal
grand jury has heard testimony in recent
months
about income and payments he received uh
while serving on the ukraine energy
company board
well we'll leave it there because we
just don't have that much more info but
i'm sure that we'll be getting more info
i'd love to interview
uh this guy in switzerland he's not
going to grant an interview to me we
could really get involved with the trash
british press
here like if we stayed here and lived
here we could like do something with the
daily mail kind of real
you know this could really be we could
really carve out an identity
what do you think you've only been in
the country for a few days but what what
are your impressions of it what do you
think i love dublin i met a guy there
that was really awesome and and i'll see
him again
uh you know dublin was a really cool
place
uh you know i connected to it as an
irish person
uh
what but this is kind of
you whereas double is my heritage
this is your heritage because i explain
to you i'm ethnic
i'm irish my grandparents came off the
boat
they you know they had gaelic sayings on
the wall
the the parties that were singing and
fighting and there's grudges and it's
irish it's irish catholic repressed
things and you know but you were really
a wasp and this is your heritage just
kind of quiet people
golf
you know somewhat dull
autistic
eccentric to a degree
you know
seville rose suits
uh you know leather boots cardigan like
this is where you kind of come from
horse you know horses
gray
oceanic climate
a little humid and windy
cold
water like
there's something about this area that
very much is your heritage do you
connect
to this area kind of the way i connected
to ireland when i saw a lot of uh people
that you know were drunk and political
reactionaries you know wandering around
the park
do you do you connect at all
to the uk and is kind of a very dry dull
you know
you know but in a really good way right
it's like london's the financial capital
of the world it's like a big
it's a big bank and everybody you know
so
it's nice people aren't screaming and
yelling it's very civilized it's very i
mean rayquan made a great point like we
don't live in a civilized country in
america we just don't
we do
the people here are so audrey taylor
green is threatening jimmy kimmel
people
people
she's said her husband will beat him up
or she went to the cops because she said
he said where's will smith when you need
her she goes he's threatening to kill me
i again it's just not a civilized
country
people are attacking each other with the
academy award it's just not
it's a grotesque it's a fun house
it's a circus
and i don't live there anymore so i
don't really judge it i just
i live at one hyde park
but
do you connect to this
do you connect to this area oh yeah
absolutely uh these are my uh
i guess are you not supposed to say
these are my people but like why the the
claw i like the tea i like the clotted
cream i like that people dress nice i
like that it's quite cream is great i
thought it was butter it was so good uh
people love golf over here and nobody's
walking around with a political
statements on their shirts uh people
smell very nice they have good hygiene
yeah i mean what's there not to love
about it
no one's screaming i love that no one's
screaming nobody's screaming everybody
has a is is is just everybody's calm
now ireland there's a little more fire
they're still talking about the
reunification of ireland i mean they'll
never stop with that
but the guy that i met he had an irish
accent and there's there's something
very attractive about an irish act don't
you don't you agree
about an irish accent yeah don't you
think it's very attractive it's a it's
the most musical accent where their
voice is like an instrument they're kind
of playing there's something attractive
about
that particular accent
you know
that i think i think that's universally
i i think is universally
um
believed
for straight guys i think it's the latin
accent and maybe maybe it's i maybe
irish makes sense too i guess
um
straight guys is the latin accent i
think so right
i don't you tell me
like because it's the it's the silver
tongued lady who gets you to take your
ring off
you know she's a silver tongue devil and
she's sort of sliding here and there
you're seeing latin people are devils no
that's not what i'm saying
no no no no no
i don't i'm missing they're they're
they're tempting you like i'm not saying
they're devils well i guess i kind of am
if you think about it the way i'm kind
of latin women
are trying to take your money
i i think they sort of fit in the role
of the siren a little bit more what
about a jew broad long island accent
like susie essman doesn't that make you
want to just come
doesn't that isn't that attractive
no but on a guy i think a dude on a guy
an irish accent
is very attractive but you're right on a
woman it's probably less attractive i
yeah i just watched an irish film
starring a woman it was scary an irish
woman just like having babies and like
you know just on the street and
being like oh father we don't have the
money
oh
they all play changelings in films where
they're like demons and stuff it's very
scary yeah well
in real life they
they you know they they don't change
nearly enough
the um
but no an irish dude like that that
accident on a guy is very attractive but
you know perhaps
i don't know perhaps and i didn't like
the i i the uncircumcised penis i think
is fine it's not a big adjustment it's
not a huge adjustment to make i thought
it'd be
more of an adjustment what do you think
about the uncircumcised people isn't it
i've always heard that they have more
nerves in their penis so you have to ask
i don't know that that's what i've heard
so then you you're more likely to come
quicker so you're not as good in bed
typically if you're um
if you have the skin well i think most
people that i have sex with are on
medication
so i don't think there nobody's coming
immediately
you know you have to put work in
everyone everyone now that's under 25 is
you know
it's you know everybody's on some like i
should get on something i should get on
i come too quickly because i'm not on
i'm not on the pill i should be on a
pill
you know
maybe i should go to the doctor and go
can i get on the pill because i want to
come later
because everybody now is just coming
later and they're happier during the day
so they're happier during the day not
filled with fear and hatred during the
day
and then they come
you know
after a while
maybe you know
and some people just not at all i don't
know some people just don't come anymore
some people go off their ssris so they
can jack off more and they end up like
having to go to like mental hospitals
and stuff because they're like they're
tired of not being able to get their
dick up anymore so they go off the meds
so they can get back into jacking off
they miss jacking off and then they go
crazy
it's pretty wild
what corner of the internet do you just
spend most of your time on it's
there's
the show in new orleans is cancelled no
one bought tickets ah sorry robert
pattinson supposedly he was going to
come
i think i heard from dasha he's so good
on red scare what does he do again uh
have you seen good time the safety
brothers movie an actor yeah
he's in batman
the batman
i can't be involved
i don't i don't know what goes on and i
i you know american culture to me is so
uninteresting
that i just don't
really
but i imagine that i imagine some people
will see that film and enjoy it but i
feel bad because him and i i think him
in the suki waterhouse part you know his
uh you know they were going to maybe
come to that show i heard but maybe
that's
not true but i feel bad but nobody
bought tickets so we got to cut it loose
i'm sorry i don't know what happened but
every other show is going i mean we've
sold like 300 tickets the theaters got
like you know what are we doing here
i thought there'd be more but you know
everybody in that city is just drunk and
so anyway
sorry
but every other show is going off as
planned and then we're in australia
we're adding shows in sydney and
melbourne
i think in brisbane and and we're going
to rock out and then the tour's over and
then we'll figure out are we going to
drop this thing as an hour are we going
to drop in clips we don't care about
your opinion
uh but it might be more fun to just drop
it in like five minute sections once a
week i don't know because then i mean
it's an hour just anyone watch
an hour who's this ben you love golf
that's a jordan spieth he's going
through a pretty big swing change
he's going through puberty
no he you know he won a lot when he was
younger and he's talking about big
golfers listen to this show right
they're kind of too dumb to really
appreciate my sense of humor they're
just big retards aren't they well
they're you always raise kids and
they're mean
and they just drink and they don't like
questioning things right so a show like
this they wouldn't like they just like
jesus and booze
yeah i think you have to kind of live on
the surface of life to be a successful
golfer yeah you can't you can't any type
of athlete
uh thinking is a detriment
to athletics
and i've said that multiple times to the
ire
of many people who think they're
athletes and aren't
but i think for most good athletes being
too introspective is a massive problem
just like if you are
killing it in a lot of businesses i'm in
one of the rare businesses where
you're it's you're paid to kind of think
but usually you just learn an algorithm
and run an algorithm over and over again
if you're a big finance you know there's
nobody sitting in the london financial
district right now that's really killing
it who's sitting there it's like yeah
but what does it all mean
[Laughter]
you know they're just doing what they
have to do right
so i think with athletes is kind of the
same thing but we have you know big
people that listen to the show and i
just wonder if any of these golfers do
if you're a big golfer let us know that
you listen to the show because ben loves
golf and it would be nice to find out
that there's a fan you know i feel like
maybe phil mickelson does cause he's the
only one that kind of has opinions on
tor and reed's book yeah but i bet he
doesn't
but um
who's did well he defended saudis on the
a couple weeks ago who's the who's the
japanese guy that's killing it nobu
hidiki matsuyama or uh sungjm he's south
korean are you talking about japanese or
south korean
that's called morkawa he is american
he grew up in glendale listen you know
what i'm what my point is
nobu nobu matsuhusha
who's
hideki matsuyama was the first japanese
call for to win the masters now he's
like the president of japan he'll never
pay for a meal the rest of his life good
for him yeah
how great is it that if if this is true
robert pattinson's ticket is going to be
refunded that's kind of funny hilarious
i don't even know if it's just probably
not true he probably has no idea who i
am but the point is if it is true
it's hilarious
that he's going to get an email saying
there is no show and i am sorry if
you're a fan of me in new orleans i
don't know what to tell you we just
can't do a show for nobody
it just doesn't work so god bless uh you
know i overestimated my draw there we're
gonna say it's a scheduling conflict but
that's a lie i'm being honest with you
uh because i'm always honest and um
that's why i'm telling you right now i'm
no longer living in the united states
i've left uh the united states of
america what tea did we have today we
had two teas oh uh yeah uh roo boy rory
boytee which is r-o-o-o
i hate that accent it's a red bush yeah
don't like the accent
now what about
i have it pulled up already this is and
i want you to tell everybody about it
tell them the story it's called dae hong
pao which is the big red robe
can i tell the story behind the tv i
want you to tell the story so supposedly
there was like an emperor in china that
was sick and he was walking along and he
met a farmer who gave him this tea right
and when he drank the tea all of his
medical conditions uh lifted and he
became well again yeah and so he gave
the farmer his big red robe so this is
called the it had leathery
but i read the full version of the story
later on his son abandoned a laptop
and even though he felt better 80 000
images of his son smoking crack and
punching hookers started to float to the
surface of the internet and there's no t
that fixes that [ __ ] america good night